la posición visiblemente fraccionada
realizó varios actos como cierre de
campaña recordemos que el próximo 21 de
noviembre no irán unidos a las urnas sin
embargo tiene un objetivo común quienes
participan y es movilizar a sus
seguidores los cuatro años y dos
elecciones consecutivas llamando a la
extensión para que recuperen la
confianza en el voto para los panelistas
también en el momento de renovar sus
liderazgos y un primer paso van a buscar
mejores condiciones para unas futuras
elecciones presidenciales voy a
participar porque aún creo en el voto
porque quiero un futuro mejor para mi
país y quedándome en mi casa de brazos
cruzados no voy a hacer absolutamente
nada por perú
sino cómo lo vamos a sacar los que hacen
cuenta que no lo queremos ya plana mayor
del gobierno acompañó de cierre de
campaña del candidato por el oficialismo
para el estado mirando y están
gobernadores los rodríguez estuvieron
presentes en el hijo de nicolás maduro y
presidente de la asamblea nacional y la
princesa presidenta del cis rodríguez y
el discurso llamar a la población a
votar en contra de las sanciones
impuestas por estados unidos ya quien
responsabilizan de las graves crisis en
materia de servicios públicos siempre
abierto al país tenemos que defender la
patria tenemos que enfrentar al pueblo
tenemos que vendrán a que el presidente
nosotros aquí en venezuela votamos por
la paz por la solidaridad
por
fortalecer mucho más la revolución
en venezuela
de la unión europea que servirán de
garantes en el proceso también habrá una
pequeña participación del centro carter
y de la organización de naciones unidas
esto por primera vez
hace años el próximo domingo se eligen
23 gobernadores 335 alcaldes y también
se renuevan las autoridades de los
concejos municipales